hi there steve kaufman here again to
talk about language learning
[Music]
i'm outside because i wanted to get
outside i've been inside
doing you know working and i said hey i
can do this outside i can do it on my
ipad
hopefully this is okay and
also if you enjoy this channel please
subscribe there's a bell you can take on
so that you can get a notification when
a new channel a newer video rather has
been put up
and if you want to learn languages the
way i do please come and visit us at
link that's where i learn languages
and any of these videos in english if
you are an english learner
you can import them from youtube into
link as a lesson
and you'll find the text there you'll
find the video there you'll find the
audio there to download
and hopefully that'll help you so today
i wanted to talk briefly about modal
verbs
because very often i get asked you know
how can i get better
more accurate in my use of modal verbs
and we i get other very specific
questions related to
aspects of english or other languages
well
my advice is you can look up you know
explanations
on modal verbs and they may or may not
make sense to you
because it's not obvious by the way a
modal verb for those of you who don't
know
those are those verbs like would could
might
ought to should need have to anything
that implies a need and obligation
those are considered modal verbs
would should could as someone once said
and
the distinction between when you use one
or as opposed to another
is not always you know 100 very often
you can use one or
other of them uh there are obviously
lots of explanations
but unless you have had enough exposure
to the language
listened enough red enough you will
never develop a natural ability to use
the correct one
and if every time you want to express
this
would should might ought to if you start
thinking through those rules
it will inhibit your speaking so my
advice
on modal verbs which is a very sort of
uh
how would you say it you know
complicated and
not obvious very often which one is
correct
it's a subtle thing that you have to
develop a natural feel for
and reading the explanation can help if
you have enough
uh experience with the language you know
to start with
but mostly it's a matter of getting used
to the language
and that is true for many other of these
very practical issues like
people say well you know you always talk
about motivation i want some practical
advice
on how to improve my english the
practical advice won't help you
the little bits and pieces and on the
other hand
there's an abundance of explanation out
there
in grammar books at google on all kinds
of aspects of using english that's not
the issue
the issue is getting more of it in you
so that your brain
gradually starts to form these patterns
so that you start to naturally
use the language accurately so that's my
advice when it comes
to modal m-o-d-a-l modal verbs you can
look it up you'll get a bunch of
explanation
but if you want to use it correctly you
have to get
the habits into your brain and that
means
lots of listening and reading speaking
getting it wrong
thinking you got it wrong when you got
it right and gradually it all just
becomes
clearer to you so having an attitude
where you accept
uncertainty not fully understanding
possibly making a mistake
and not letting that bother you that's
more important
than reading any explanation on modal
verbs
so thank you for listening bye for now
[Music]